rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une petite balade très facile le long du
rempart du net boeufs
rendez vous sur la route forestière du
volcan après le nez de boeuf et avant le
piton textor
notre accompagnateur du jour sera
alexandre ped du parc national
depuis ce petit parking aménagé en
dessous du piton de sable il est
possible de récupérer le sentier qui
monte jusqu'au piton textor
mais c'est dans l'autre sens que nous
l'empruntons direction le nez de boeuf
par un sentier coups faciles et sans
dénivelé idéal en redescendant du volcan
où avant un pique nique
le sentier traverse des prairies aux
couleurs exotiques mais qui recèle aussi
quelques belles orchidées pays comme
cette satire yom ha - hommes son nom
vient du mot satire et l'on comprend
pourquoi en examinant la fleur dont une
partie évoque une paire de cornes
sur ce sentier la route n'est jamais
très loin
ni le bord du rempart principal intérêt
de la balade qui permet malgré les
nuages du jour de jeter un oeil au fond
de la rivière des remparts
l'occasion d'en apprendre un peu plus
sur la formation de cette vallée ce qui
est remarquable ici c'est que c'est une
formation géologique déjà plus ancienne
que toutes celles qu'on voit on
lorsqu'on va vers le conte se rapproche
du pas de bellecombe celle ci c'est
vraiment l'une des premières phases du
piton de la fournaise où il ya eu un
effondrement complètement du massif là
dans l'eau est venue elle a fait un gros
travail d'érosion et par derrière tout
ça il ya quand même eu le commerçant qui
est venu qui a re re re minute d'écoulée
par dessus qui est venu combler le tout
et qui a donné toute cette zone convoi
de plus ou moins aplanies au fond de la
rivière qui a été re colonisé après par
une forêt de essentiellement de bois de
couleurs et de branches
on se rapproche ensuite une haie de
boeuf par un sentier aux allures
champêtres
mal avec la con
lee
finalement la pluie ne nous épargne pas
d'abord timide puis franche un saint
vite
heureusement qu'on nous terminons cette
balade au niveau de l'ère de pique nique
du nez ce bug
la 3d
g
et pour rejoindre notre point de départ
on pourra revenir sur nos plats ou
continuent de l'autre côté de la route
sur un autre sentier
vous
non
m
l'intérêt de cette randonnée c'est que
c'est une randonnée vraiment facile
accessible à tout le monde plus grand
public sont en famille avec les
marmailles pour ce soir la randonnée
sans difficultés particulières il ya
moyen de faire une boucle faire même un
aller retour et le fait de longer tout
ce rempart l'heure donc en partant nous
on est parti de deux d'en haut pour
redescendre vers le nez de boeuf mais le
voilà on peut le faire dans n'importe
quel sens se garer sur ce parc
ce parking cet espace de pique nique sur
lequel on est et il ya moyen de voir
quand même l'idée d'avoir une idée de ce
qui est du massif du volcan
parce que j'aime quand même moins sur
cette randonnée c'est leurs bêtes
ce qui est quand même récurrence et le
les déchets on en voit bien qu'on en
voit de moins en moins mais on en trouve
toujours il ya ce jour l'un d'incivilité
quelque part et elle sait qu on voit que
les invasif sans comprendre le dessus
sur nos plantes endémiques que nos
plantes qui assure notre patrimoine
naturel ici pose déjà constaté un taux
long du sentier qui a de l'ajonc
d'europe ou bien partir sur la zone
incendiée et on va encore les branles
calcinées il ya l'acacia mais andy ce
sila qui entraîne bien reprendre le
dessus même qui attaquent les flancs de
remparts donc autant dire que ma cc
c'est fini on pourra pas avoir réguler
ces lézards été stoppé cette invasion là
à partir du moment où c'est un prix le
bourg de remparts c'est encore trop
abrupte et c'est impossible de freiner
tout ça ça fait mal au coeur